because i work hard
and it people might get the wrong idea
because sometimes i might have a 20
minute break
and i'll savor it i'll be with the kids
for 20 minutes i'll be like
ah and i'll do a little video and this
but that's 20 minutes
and then i'm back on it and i don't even
have to do that but you've you've just
gotta
you've gotta work hard if you haven't
got time maybe get up an hour earlier
you know so you're a university student
call
just just work hard manage your time
and just accept that if you're young
you've got to put the hours in
and how bad do you want it how bad do
you want it
i mean if you if if you're doing work
and you're loving it i mean
how about how hard did i work when i was
22 man very hard like ridiculous
when i was 19. we did i still work hard
now
but then i did all the hard work with no
play
no play at all um i used to get up at
5am go to a networking event
then i used to then i should start my
day after the networking development
finished
like 9am i'd do my whole day and then my
day would finish at like 6pm
and then i'd drive to a networking event
and do a pin meeting or i'd speak or
whatever then i'd network at the bar
afterwards 10 till 11 then i go home i
get back about half past midnight
boom same story that was my standard day
six days a week that was what i did like
constantly
i drive to edinburgh just to go and
just to go and speak to 10 property
investors you know rather than saying
like oh where
how can i find property investors i'd
just be like okay where are property
investors
anybody else no promoter didn't i i'll
go
oh i've got to be there there's 10
property investors there i'm going to go
and i'm going to tell them about my
products i'm going to tell them about my
services i'm going to pitch them some
deals
i'm going to try and get them to join
adventure with me and guess what if no
one does and i have to leave
empty-handed no problem
at least i've got their business cards
i've whacked them on my mailing list
seven of them now are on my mailing list
great next like that's
that's the kind of dogged determination
and maniac
business savviness you need to get if
if you want to be really successful if
you want to be a bit successful
you know you want to be financially free
and make two and a half thousand pounds
a month in rental income no problem you
can do that
just by working a few hours a week oh it
give it some years
no problem you'll be really successful
or you want to become financially free
really fast
you just gotta go crazy and everyone has
the same amount of hours in the day
the um you know donald trump has the
same amount of hours a day as i have in
the day as russell does
as the employee as the housewife as
everybody and i'm not judging anyone or
saying anyone's in a better position
understand we would have taken that time
so time i i just don't see time it can
possibly be an excuse
personally do you what do you think i
agree i mean your channel is great i
subscribed
i know what's he said back um he said
thanks samuel i thought i was working
hard but obviously not hard enough
maybe you are working hard maybe maybe
you're working hard but you haven't done
it for long enough
to see the results what are you saying
it's also about like
eliminating the stuff that you don't
need to do yeah like we do
so much stuff i mean nonsense
i think it might be like darren hardy or
someone but he was talking about
he he decided to clock every time he did
something during the day that was really
worthwhile and he was like and he got
and he was ashamed at the end of the day
it was like an hour let me show you
something okay
you know my mailbox unread mail
is obviously you want to keep that at a
minimum right you don't want loads of
messages that are
read on your mailbox here's my mailbox
i don't know if you can see that there
are my two mailboxes
so i got i got 1 212
undealt with emails right here and you
can see that and then here
5670 500
5670 oh there we go
then i undealt with emails
now people are like oh my goodness
that's terrible samuel what a bad time
management person you are
no no no no no i don't care
i'm not interested not interested
i'm only interested in getting done what
i want to get done
that's it i don't want to get done what
i want to get done i don't want to
answer everybody's call
i don't want to respond to everybody i
don't care i don't care i'm good
i'm just doing what needs to get done
and people whistles like oh geez do you
agree
people here's what people do they
check their emails they make sure
there's no unread messages they return
their phone calls off everybody
and they spend their whole muscle same
story man
russell's unread emails i don't even see
this
can you see it hold on hold on where is
going close with us so fifteen thousand
six hundred and sixteen undealt with
emails
just well you look stressed man are you
stressed are you okay okay are you okay
i'm good are you good are you good
brother
guess how he feels guess how he feels
about that he doesn't care
why because he just wants to get done
what needs to get done
and what happens is too many people
worry about
everybody else's urgent issues oh i need
to get back to this person because they
told me it was urgent that they sound
stressed let them be stressed i'm not
stressed i'm good
they're stressed i don't care
i'm just doing what needs to be done and
that's how you got to do business
because if you honestly
and you might think oh i don't like that
samuel that's unconsiderate
i don't care i don't care i'm gonna i
piss off a lot of people guess what
i don't care i don't care people live
their whole business life trying not to
upset people
trying to be liked trying not to piss
people off
and all they do is they're just
responding responding responding
responding getting up in the day they're
responding to calls they're responding
they're responding or responding i don't
respond to anything i don't want to
respond to what i do
is i get done what needs to get done
and in the same way to my friend that
was talking about time management
what i'd say is what do you need to get
done this year
this month this week write it down don't
do anything else you get all these
messages from people telling you to do
stuff
who cares because once you look after
yourself you might think it's selfish
but i tell you what
i do more for people than most people do
we've got samuel lee's foundation we're
building schools we're bringing clean
water out to africa
i'm doing a lot we're doing a lot as a
business we give 10 of our
turnover not profit turnover we give we
give to charity
so i'm not saying be a selfish prick and
don't care about anybody
what i'm saying is focus focus
you know you just try and please
everybody and respond to everybody and
that you're not gonna get anything done
and you're gonna have a never-ending
to-do list do you know how long might
you do this this i haven't got to-do
list
i don't even have to do this i have a
done list
i ring up rustle every day and tell you
this is what i've done today what have
you done that's why i'm doing it
what have you done today brother uh i've
done this and this
doesn't sound that productive to me
brother let me tell you what i've done
bro like that's what we do we we don't
compare to do lists
who give some monkeys about your to-do
list everyone's got to do this
just my to-do list and then you love
ticking it off right
ticking it off and then it's never
ending and forget that don't have a
to-do list
what have you done pre-done this week
that's why i want to ask you
on every call on wednesday what have you
done over the last week i wanna hear
what you've done
what have you done get yourself a done
list and if you have got to do this only
have four or five things on your to-do
list and have it for the whole year and
say
i don't do these five things firstly if
i do these five things this year it'll
be a good year
for me there's only a few things if i do
these few things this year it'll be a
good year
so one of the things was putting all my
academy training courses online
that's just one one thing another one is
getting down into the four teams
in weight that's one thing okay a few
things
by the end of the year if i've done all
those things if i put all my courses on
online if i've made this much money if
i've got down to my ideal weight that
would have been a good year right
well forget everything else i need to
focus on these four things that's it
everything else can wait i don't care
about it that's four things
then every day i would say well if i'd
done towards these four things
so i said to us what you're doing i've
worked out nice what else
i've i've of um sold all of our one of
our new build properties
great cool what else and i've also
updated all our t's and c's
great cool nice job here's what i've
done that's how you need to start
thinking